(applause)
- You know I love stores that
put a smile on your face.
I find them and serve them
up fresh. You're welcome.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(crowd applauds and cheers)
Last Christmas, I introduced you
to an amazing second grader
from upstate New York.
Eight year old Santii had
a simple Christmas wish:
to raise money for new
playground equipment
everyone could enjoy, even kids
in wheelchairs. Take a look.
(swooshing sound)
I hear Santii that you were
inspired to give back after a trip
to the playground one day,
can you tell us what happened?
- Well, I saw a little
girl in a wheelchair
and she couldn't play with anything.
So, I thought all kids in wheelchairs
would like accessible swing,
so they could feel the wind in their hair.
(swooshing sound)
(crowd applauds and cheers)
- Oh my god, so cute.
After our show, Santii
got a call from the city.
They were so inspired.
They didn't just want
to buy new equipment.
They wanted to build a brand new park.
So on top of our $5,000,
they kicked in 165,000.
(crowd applauds and cheers)
To build a state of the art park
the most inclusive and accessible
in all of New York state.
It just opened up last month and get this:
Santii's name is actually
on the equipment.
(crowd applauds and cheers)
Let's get her in here
along with her mama, Becca.
Hi y'all!
(crowd applauds and cheers)
- Hi!
- Hello!
I am so proud of you.
I mean, you must be blown away.
Like this is an advanced
park. Can you tell us about?
- There this is amazing We-Go-Swing
and it looks like a boat
and kids and wheelchairs
and you can go on it
and you pump it back and forth.
And then there's this amazing We-Go-Round
that has my name on it.
And I also got to help build it.
(crowd applauds and cheers)
...spin it really fast!
And two kids in wheel chairs click in
so they're nice and safe.
It's awesome!
(crowd applauds and cheers)
- Oh my gosh!
I love you so much, Santii,
you are... you just make
me smile inside out.
So you're also planning on
expanding everything, right?
- Yes.
- Okay. So what's up? What's
the new thing you want to do?
- Match you guys on a slide!
(crowd applauds and laughs)
- I love it.
My kids love slides.
Well, thank you so much, Santii
and Becca for joining us.
I'm liking your posts right now, okay?
(crowd applauds and cheers)
And that's not all!
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
the go-to pen of The
Kelly Clarkson Show likes
to celebrate those who create
fearlessly, just like you.
So they'll be using their
friction erasable pen
to write you a check
for a thousand dollars.
(applause and laughter)
I love you!